Traducteur: Michele Gianella
Relecteur: Hélène Vernet
On ne vous voit presque pas
mais je savais que ça allait
être impressionnant.
Ce n'est pas que vous soyez 400
qui est impressionnant,
ni même les quelques milliers
qui vont me regarder à la télé.
Non, ce qui m'épate -
vous n'en avez peut-être pas conscience -
c'est que vous êtes
quatre cent gens...
à venir...
et vous êtes consentants, à l'avance.
Vous ne savez pas de quoi je vais parler
mais vous êtes consentants.
Alors bravo, merci pour votre confiance.
Ça vraiment, c'est super.
(Applaudissements)
Alors, on va commencer l'expérience.
La question « apporte-bonheur ».
J'ai un sujet très sérieux
à vous communiquer, à vous partager,
parce que c'est un élan
extraordinaire de ma vie,
mais je voudrais,
avant de passer dans des explications
un peu complexes, économiques...
Ah, non ! Vous n'avez rien vu.
Donc, avant de vous dire
de quoi je vais vous parler,
je voudrais vous faire vivre
une petite expérience.
Alors pour ça, je vais
vous demander de vous concentrer.
D'abord asseyez-vous.
Je sais que vous êtes déjà assis,
je ne suis pas que blonde,
mais je vous demande de vous
asseoir confortablement, consciemment.
Voilà, ça gigote déjà. Déjà, vous voyez.
Vous n'êtes pas de bons élèves;
on a entendu des bruits.
Donc, c'est bon ?
Tout le monde est concentré ?
Vous aussi derrière vos écrans,
je vous vois.
Je vais faire appel à votre concentration
sur vos sensations,
vos émotions, votre imagination.
Je vous demande de mettre de côté
votre petite raison qui dit :
« Qu'est-ce qu'elle va faire ? », etc.
Chuuut !
(Rires)
J'adore ma raison.
Quelquefois elle est très utile.
Mais quelquefois - elle adore
que je la grattouille ici -
il faut la calmer un peu.
Donc, vous faites un câlin
à vos pensées, à votre mental.
Vous le rangez et là...
Vous allez fermer les yeux,
s'il vous plaît.
Vous fermez les yeux et vous imaginez
qu'à partir du mois prochain,
vous recevez sur votre compte
en banque, suffisamment pour vivre.
Une fois, deux fois,
le mois suivant, ça se répète.
Et ça jusqu'à la fin de votre vie !
Il n'y a rien à faire, ça tombe tout cuit.
Si vous bossez,
c'est en plus, c'est cumulable.
Et ce n'est pas seulement vous,
mais vos proches aussi.
Alors attention, question !
Qu'est-ce que ça change pour vous ?
Avec ce revenu de base,
qu'est-ce que ça va changer
au niveau du travail ?
De la famille ?
Du temps libéré peut-être...
Du pouvoir d'achat supplémentaire...
Je vous laisse explorer un petit peu.
Goûtez-le.
Alors, je suis obligée de vous interrompre
parce qu'on est un peu chronométrés.
Je vais vous demander
de revenir parmi nous...
Voilà. Alors, j'ai observé
un petit peu les réactions.
J'ai vu des grands soupirs.
Je pense que là, il y a peut-être
des pensées qui vous sont venues du type :
« Ah, la fin de mois va être plus cool,
et la fin de vie aussi peut-être.
Et comme les enfants l'ont aussi,
le milieu de ma vie
sera certainement soulagé.
Je ne vais pas devoir bosser tout le temps
pour économiser
pour les sécuriser post-mortem.
Je vais peut-être pouvoir
les voir grandir. »
Çà, c'est un premier élan
qui peut vous venir.
Oui, le revenu de base est censé -
permettez-moi une fois
le jeu de mots débile -
combler les besoins de base.
Jusque là, ça va.
D'ailleurs ça tombe bien,
parce que l'article 25
de la Déclaration des Droits de l'homme
et du citoyen et de la citoyenne
cite quatre besoins.
Elle commence comme ça :
« Toute personne a droit
à un niveau de vie suffisant... »
Là, on pourrait s'arrêter,
mais elle cite ces quatre besoins-là :
alimentation, santé,
habillement, logement,
et après elle enchaîne sur :
« pour être sécurisé en cas de maladie,
de maternité, de vieillesse, etc. »
Donc finalement, c'est déjà un droit.
Il ne reste plus qu'à avoir
les moyens de ce droit.
Cela nous apporte un profond
sentiment de sécurité,
de sécurité matérielle bien sûr,
c'est la définition,
mais aussi de sécurité psychologique.
Aujourd'hui, vous connaissez
certainement des gens qui travaillent,
et qui pourtant connaissent
le sentiment, la peur de la précarité.
Après la sécurité, il y a les sourires.
C'est : « Ouah, tout
est possible ! C'est la liberté.
Tous les projets
que j'ai du laisser tomber ! »
Avec le temps libre
par rapport au travail,
tout ce qui a pu vous venir...
La liberté et la créativité.
Entreprendre ? Sécurisé !
Être artiste ? Sécurisé !
Inventer ? Sécurisé !
Faire des TEDx ? Sécurisé!
C'est extraordinaire !
Après la liberté, vient le sens,
parce que vos choix, vous les ferez
en cohérence avec vos valeurs,
avec votre rythme aussi,
au fil de la vie, au fil
de la semaine, au fil du mois,
vous pourrez gérer tout ça
et gagner en confiance en soi -
ce qui va avec
la confiance aux autres.
Alors, c'est rigolo
parce que c'est réciproque.
C'est un cercle vertueux
et c'est contagieux.
Donc la confiance est sur une base
d'égalité et de justice
puisque tout le monde l'a à la naissance.
Vous naissez reconnu comme un individu,
un être humain avec des besoins,
et ces besoins sont pris
en charge par la société
à laquelle vous participez -
ça tombe bien, c'est bien fait.
Et tout ça se conclut
sur le besoin de paix
qu'on a tous au fond de nous,
aussi différents que nous soyons -
on a parlé de bonheur tout à l'heure -
besoin de paix intérieure, individuelle,
et besoin de paix collective, sociale.
On ouvre là un champ énorme
sur un nouveau contrat social.
Tous les besoins, j'espère
vous les avoir fait un petit peu goûter
parce que c'était pour moi
le plus important.
Je pourrais m'arrêter là sauf que,
il y a cette petite voix que j'imagine,
vous avez aussi, qui vous dit :
« C'est bien de rêver
mais qu'est ce qu'on en fait ?
Maintenant qu'on les a alléchés,
on ne va pas les laisser comme ça.
La frustration, c'est mauvais
pour la santé, etc., etc.
Chuuut ! Ouh, c'est compliqué.
Donc, on va lui répondre.
Je vais tout vous dire ou presque,
tout ce qui rentrera dans 18 minutes.
Hop !
Le revenu de base, c'est quoi ?
C'est une idée, un concept,
avec plein de concrétisations différentes,
dans tous les sens,
avec des projets de société,
des leviers de financement,
plein de différences.
Là, je vais revenir aux fondamentaux,
à la base, la définition.
Le revenu de base est individuel.
Il est inconditionnel.
Vous travaillez ou pas, vous l'avez.
Il est cumulable avec tout type de revenu.
Il est inaliénable, on ne pourra
jamais vous l'enlever,
d'ailleurs il n'est pas imposable,
forcément...
Et il est universel.
Evidemment, on va commencer
par des expérimentations,
mais l'ambition est universelle
et c'est important.
Une fois qu'on a vu cette définition-là -
maintenant vous savez de quoi je parle -
on peut parler sur des bases communes.
Alors, cette petite voix qui va
vous parler a trois type d'objections.
Ce sont par exemple :
"Ah non, ça ne va pas
du tout. Pas d'accord !
Il y a un mot de la définition
qui me bloque.
'Inconditionnel' par exemple.
Enfin, on ne va pas donner de l'argent
à rien faire ! Vous rigolez ? »
Bon ça se fait déjà, on a un filet social
en France, heureusement.
Mais voilà, il peut y avoir
des blocages comme ça
qu'on va appeler
« la valeur travail », etc.
Il y a des réponses possibles,
on pourrait en discuter des heures
mais, je n'ai pas le temps,
donc très rapidement :
quand je garde ou fait garder mon enfant,
c'est quoi la différence ?
Hé bien, d'un côté
c'est rémunéré, de l'autre non.
Pourtant, la vertu sociale est la même.
N'y a-t-il pas des métiers
qui peuvent être inutiles
ou voire nuisibles à l'environnement,
à notre santé, etc. ?
Est-ce que la rémunération est
une reconnaissance de l'utilité sociale ?
Pas forcément.
Après il y a la question
de la productivité
qui explose et devrait
nous libérer du temps.
Les machines, les logiciels,
ça sert à quoi
si ce n'est libérer l'homme
et la femme du travail.
Alors, on pourrait partager ce temps
libéré, les bénéfices aussi d'ailleurs.
Mais, on ne le fait pas.
Donc voilà, il y a ce type de réponse.
Je ne peux pas rentrer dans chaque mot
ou chaque contre-arguments.
Je vous laisserai le loisir
de les étudier plus tard.
Le deuxième type d'objection, c'est :
« Oui, mais attention!
Si on installe un revenu de base,
il risque d'arriver des dérives. »
C'est vrai.
Alors, d'abord, bravo !
Tu as réussi à passer
la première étape : l'utopie.
C'est dire : « Oui, c'est une utopie,
ce n'est pas possible »,
donc, on jette à la poubelle,
on ne regarde même pas.
Là, vous avez vu,
il y a quand même un « oui ».
Bon, il y a un «mais »,
mais c'est un « mais » constructif.
Si par exemple, vous dites :
« Avec un revenu une base,
il risque d'y avoir
la hausse des prix
ou la baisse des salaires. »
Oui, possible.
Donc, on prend ça
en compte, puis on se dit:
« Qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait faire
pour éviter ça? »
On peut mettre en place
telle et telle mesure
qu'on va ajouter au revenu de base
pour en faire un projet de société.
Finalement, un revenu
de base, c'est quoi?
C'est un outil, et ça dépend comment
on va l'utiliser, dans quelle intention.
Le dernier type d'argument,
c'est le « Oui, mais comment? »
Grande angoisse aussi!
Alors là, double félicitation:
non seulement vous êtes passés
au-dessus de l'utopie,
mais vous avez réussi
à surmonter les peurs
en les transformant en moteurs.
Et donc, on arrive à la faisabilité.
On arrive aux premières
réflexions de transition.
Nos politiques sont à ce niveau-là.
Nous, pas encore; il est temps
qu'on les rejoignent,
parce qu'ils ont un peu besoin
de nous pour les guider.
Donc, après les contre-arguments,
je vais répondre quand même,
parce que je la connais,
cette raison-là et j'en ai entendu.
C'est toujours la même
[question] qui revient :
« Oui, mais comment ça se finance?
Où est-ce qu'on va trouver l'argent? »
On est bien conditionnés
parce que chaque bonne idée,
on la conditionne d'avance au financement,
alors que ça pourrait être le contraire.
Mais, ce n'est pas grave,
je vais lui répondre.
Hop !
La première chose, c'est d'abord
qu'il y a plein de financements.
Plein !
Il y a plein de recherches partout.
Alors, imaginons:
« Allez braves gens,
c'est ma dernière offre,
2 000 euros par mois pour tout le monde.
Allez, dépêchez-vous d'en profiter
ça sera pas pour tout le monde,
ça ne sera pas tout le temps, etc..»
Et alors là, vous voyez l'astérisque?
« Et nous privatisons
tous les services publics,
la sécu, les retraites, etc. »
« Ah, pas bon! » Méfiez-vous.
Il y a des régressions sociales
qui se cachent parmi les revenus de base.
Un revenu de base n'est pas fait
pour faire des économies.
Un revenu de base,
c'est une avancée sociétale
du même ordre que le droit
de vote universel,
ou alors la sécu elle-même,
ou le droit au logement, etc.
Les premières versions
qu'on pourra soutenir,
c'est celles qui sont
de l'autofinancement,
c'est-à-dire on prend toutes les aides
que l'Etat donne déjà,
on les met dans un grand sac,
puis on le découpe et on le répartit.
Tout le monde a la même chose.
On arrive à des montants
d'à peu près 500 euros,
en France, par personne et par mois.
C'est le montant des minima sociaux.
Objectif: simplifier
la redistribution par l'Etat.
Donc, on rationalise un petit peu
les différents services, etc.
On simplifie aussi
pour ceux qui le reçoivent
parce que remplir des dossiers,
c'est souvent humiliant,
et il y a une sacrée stigmatisation
qu'on minimise souvent.
On ne touche pas trop
aux inégalités sociales
mais on enlève la grande pauvreté
car au moins, notre filet
de protection n'a plus de trous,
vous savez, les 18-25, le premier
enfant par rapport au deuxième, etc.
Donc ça, c'est le premier levier,
après, tous les autres leviers
vont avoir pour ambition
d'atteindre de plus en plus
le seuil de pauvreté
qui en France avoisine les 1 000 euros.
On essaye d'arriver
à une certaine suffisance -
le mot est toujours discutable -
mais vers 1 000 euros, on peut estimer
qu'on a atteint le seuil de pauvreté.
Après, on va de plus en plus
vers une émancipation de l'individu
par rapport à son patron,
par exemple,
pouvoir négocier ses conditions de travail
jusqu'à quelquefois
pouvoir refuser un travail, etc.
Pour y arriver, il y a
des leviers de fiscalité.
Là, je peux vous faire
une heure minimum sur la fiscalité,
et encore, j'y connais rien.
Vous allez taper « Revenudebase.info »
pour compléter ce TEDx
qui ne dure que 18 minutes à peu près.
Bref, des fiscalités dans tous les sens,
des taxes, de l'impôt sur revenu,
de la cotisation,
il y a plein de recherches en cours
qui vont varier dans des montants
entre 700 et 1 500 euros.
On peut avoir aussi
une réflexion plus générale:
Pourquoi un revenu que monétaire?
On peut le transformer en services,
élargir services publics, biens communs,
au niveau local et national,
tout est possible, et recherché aussi.
La création monétaire :
elle est souvent méconnue.
Nous avons la monnaie locale
qui va, adossée à l'euro,
fructifier l'économie sociale
et solidaire d'un territoire ;
on a la monnaie nationale, possible,
la monnaie européenne.
Savez-vous que la BCE,
notre Banque Centrale Européenne,
crée 80 milliards d'euros,
à partir de rien puisque
ce n'est évidemment plus de l'or,
tous les mois, qu'elle distribue
d'un côté aux banques privées,
de l'autre côté aux grandes entreprises.
Ça donne envie ?
Il y a un projet qui dit
que tout cet argent-là,
on pourrait le donner directement
à chacun et chacune,
chaque citoyen européen pourrait avoir
environ 150 euros
par mois et par citoyen. »
Nous, on l'utiliserait comment?
On l'utiliserait dans nos frais
de tous les jours,
c'est-à-dire dans l'économie réelle -
une sacrée plus-value
pour l'économie européenne.
Et il y a les monnaies libres
qui elles, sont sans frontières,
qui existent déjà - vous tapez
sur internet, vous trouvez tout.
Le dernier levier n'est pas quantifiable
mais on a quand même quelques indices,
et vous remarquerez
la transition habile de la speaker
puisque je passe des économies prévisibles
aux expérimentations
qui nous ont donné ces indices-là.
Par exemple au Canada,
ils ont fait une expérience
sur deux villes.
Je ne vais vous donner qu'un chiffre
pour être succincte et efficace:
8,5 % en moins d'hospitalisations.
Ça fait rêver.
Surtout en maladie professionnelle,
en accident du travail
et tout ce qui est maladie « psycho. »
Quand on sait que les Français
sont les champions des antidépresseurs,
il y a certainement
un filon d'économies par là.
J'enchaîne avec les Etats-Unis
qui ont fait plusieurs expérimentations,
notamment quatre dans les années 60-70.
Eux, leur angoisse, c'était:
« Oui mais, si on donne un revenu de base,
plus personne n'ira travailler.»
Donc, ils ont compté
les heures de travail,
et figurez-vous que si,
les gens continuent à travailler.
Masos ou pas, je n'en sais rien,
mais il n'y a que deux
catégories de personnes
qui travaillent sensiblement moins,
entre 10 et 30 %:
les étudiants et les jeunes mamans.
Pas besoin de sous-titrer pourquoi.
Donc à priori, c'était
une super expérimentation
mais il y a eu un petit dégât collatéral,
quelque chose de rien du tout,
mais qui en a inquiété certains:
c'est le nombre de divorces.
On est dans les années 70
et les dames n'avait pas d'autonomie
financière à cette époque-là,
et donc recevoir le revenu de base,
leur a fait regarder un peu
différemment leur relation conjugale.
C'est malheureux à dire mais oui,
certaines se sont dit :
« Ma relation conjugale n'est
que de la sécurité financière. »
Les conservateurs ont hurlé:
« Ah! On détruit la cellule familiale,
on détruit toute la société américaine!»
Sauf que dans l'expérimentation
qui a duré onze ans,
le taux de mariage remonte,
donc ça prouve que ce n'est pas
un problème avec le mariage,
mais par contre un bon indice
d'émancipation féminine dans le couple -
je pense qu'on pourrait
l'espérer encore aujourd'hui -
mais aussi, pourquoi pas, l'élargir
avec l'employeur ?
Les femmes sont aujourd'hui,
celles qui subissent le plus
de temps partiel non choisi,
d'inégalités salariales, etc.
J'enchaîne avec l'expérimentation en Inde
qui a été initiée par l'UNICEF
et un syndicat de travailleuses.
Alors là, extraordinaire!
Les résultats:
endettement divisé par trois,
scolarité multipliée par trois,
x 3 aussi d'activités économiques,
des investissements sur la santé,
la scolarisation des enfants,
le logement, surtout en termes sanitaires,
et les outils de travail;
et avec tout ça, moins 14 % d'anxiété.
Ne me demandez pas
comment ils ont testé ça,
mais, le chiffre est intéressant.
Je termine avec
un dernier exemple: la Namibie.
Pendant deux ans, un village
de 1 000 habitants
Je vous passe les effets
qu'on a déjà vu ailleurs:
scolarisation 92 %, meilleure santé,
activité économique qui explose, etc.
Il y a aussi un effet en plus,
c'est la baisse de la criminalité.
Oui, ça sert à quoi d'aller
tout casser, de frauder et de voler
alors qu'on a ce qu'il nous faut?
Voilà, donc ce sont des effets
qui ne sont pas tous transférables
mais qui sont intéressants.
Il y a, dans cette expérimentation,
un autre effet intéressant,
c'est que le FMI est intervenu.
Il a vérifié tous les chiffres,
parce que cette expérience-là,
il fallait vérifier sa rentabilité.
Il a dit « Non, ce n'est pas possible.
ce n'est pas rentable du tout, regardez!»
Et les citoyens,
ces irréductibles villageois,
se sont constitués en comité
et ont montré
que le FMI s'était « trompé »
dans ses chiffres.
En fait, c'était complètement rentable,
et pas seulement financièrement
mais en termes humains aussi,
en « coût humain » comme on dit.
Et ils se sont, avec leurs petits comités,
leurs petits bras et leurs petites jambes,
ils sont allés voir
tous les villages alentour
et ils ont sillonné toute la Namibie
pour témoigner.
Et aujourd'hui, qu'est-ce qu'il se passe?
Le ministère est en train
de réfléchir très sérieusement
à une généralisation du revenu de base
sur tout le territoire.
Je ne vais pas pouvoir tout vous dire -
[Voir] Revenudebase.info
en sortant d'ici -
mais, il y a des expérimentations
partout, passées, en cours et à venir.
Je conclurai sur un petit
point intéressant,
que vous voyez à peu près
au milieu de l'Europe
et qui s'appelle la France.
Il y a des projets en France déjà,
au niveau d'un éco-hameau,
d'un département,
d'une région, d'une nation.
Donc je conclurai là-dessus:
le revenu de base est déjà là.
La question maintenant c'est, lequel?
Lequel vous ferez exister ?
Alors au boulot!
Merci!
(Applaudissements)